campagne d'affichage en plein métro à
paris à nantes à lyon ou encore en
angleterre encarts publicitaires cette
année orléans met le paquet pour attirer
les city breakers les citadins à la
recherche de court séjour à une heure de
paris on a des vrais atouts et c'est
vrai que la vie la lame beaucoup
d'atouts aussi que ce soit patrimoniaux
notre fleuve la loi patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco
on a les jardins on a un art de vivre
qui reconnut maintenant il suffit
d'ailleurs de se promener dans les rues
d'orléans pour voir le nombre de
touristes et qui viennent maintenant
pour vraiment découvrir aurélien son art
de son art de vivre
le défi est de taille car il faut
rattraper le retard en terme d'image par
rapport à d'autres encore aujourd'hui
orléans est considérée comme une ville
de passage en l'ayant et sa métropole
ont d'abord privilégié une certaine
logique ses talents rénover son
territoire son centre historique son
patrimoine
et maintenant que tout ça est en ordre
de bataille maintenant il faut le faire
savoir
l'enjeu est aussi important pour les
hôtels 67% de leur clientèle provient
habituellement du tourisme d'affaires
avec les city breakers leur objectif est
désormais de remplir les chambres en
période creuse
il faut tout essayer pour ça fonctionne
tout tenté nous avons des stocks de
chambre qui sont périssables une chambre
qui n'est pas vendu et ben c'est pas
vendus et on peut pas rattraper la vente
donc je trouve que c'est une bonne idée
d'avoir fait cette campagne d'affichage
qui donnera envie peut-être à des
parisiens
qui ne partent pas en vacances de dieu
tient sur un petit short brake passer
des termes anglo-saxons mais un petit
court séjour sur orléans en six ans les
city break aux escapades urbaines ont
progressé de 47% au niveau mondial la
ville d'orléans est désormais prête à
prendre sa part du gâteau